just seven words have plunged us
national basketball into a geopolitical
crisis with billions of dollars in
Chinese sponsorship and TV rights at
stake on Friday daryl morey general
manager of the Houston Rockets NBA team
tweeted fight for freedom stand with
Hong Kong in support of anti-government
demonstrations there China is furious it
regularly complains about what it sees
has foreign interference in internal
matters we are not apologizing for
Darrel exercising his freedom of
expression
I regret again having communicated
directly with many friends in China that
so many people are upset including
millions and millions of our fans
frantic attempts by Mori and the NBA to
pacify China have resulted in fierce
criticism particularly from US
politicians Hong Kong has been part of
China under the one country two systems'
plan since it was handed over by the UK
in 1997 just months after paying
billions of dollars to extend its
streaming deal with the NBA Chinese
company Tencent says it won't show any
more rocket schemes effectively cutting
the Houston team off from Chinese
basketball fans so as a raucous fan and
very disappointed as a Chinese I feel
very disappointed by his comments
basketball is popular in China Chinese
star Yao Ming played his entire Hall of
Fame career with the Houston Rockets
he's now a chairman of the China
Basketball Association which says it's
canceling a cooperation agreement with
the Rockets the NBA is not the only
organization to have to apologize in the
face of Chinese anger in the past gap
the Marriott Hotel Group and Daimler car
company have all had to backtrack the
Hong Kong airline Cathay Pacific even
sacked some of its staff who publicly
supported the protests in Hong Kong
because it was worried it was going to
lose access to viable Chinese airspace
analysts say anyone who accepts Chinese
investment should be aware of China's
sensitivities
he crossed the line and then which is
many sponsor investor or partner from
oversea they know it they know it
shouldn't you know no one should say it
China is not the only country to use
investment as leverage a critics say
that when the NBA has been faced with a
choice between freedom of speech and the
risk of losing billions of dollars
china's money talks
rob matheson al jazeera beijing